benoît hamon ministre en charge de la
consommation de l'économie sociale et
solidaire est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat en
partenariat avec dailymotion dailymotion
vous connaissez bien maintenant à
mercedes à benoît hamon y avait avec l'
agence france-presse représenter ce soir
par karine perdrait et perrine tarneaud
bien sûr de public sénat nous rejoindra
à la fin de l'émission vous êtes un
parmi sept
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
d'avoir trouvé votre place à bercy
d'abord oui oui oui
est ce que vous êtes en manque de chef
non votre c qui présentait république et
le premier ministre est entre pierre
moscovici arnaud montebourg n'y a pas de
compétition c'est que ça marche pas
ainsi mogère ministre de tutelle c'est
pierre moscovici avec lequel je
travaille sur le projet de loi
consommation sur laquelle que je déjà
présente au conseil des ministres
on va parler un travail est en très
bonne intelligence donc
il n'y a pas de problème de hiérarchie
croit aujourd'hui à bercy il a pu y
avoir des cas du brouillage sur la ligne
sur un stand de sujets je crois pas
qu'il ait problème de hiérarchie un
quart des français verrait bien martine
aubry à la version est ce que vous en
faites partie sondage journal du
dimanche mais le président la république
a approuvé cette question n'est pas
d'actualité au remaniement
alors à tous les cas si un remaniement
est en réflexion pour mercy avec
l'écrêtement par exemple ton en deux
pôles vous n'avez pas encore la réponse
est claire en revanche vous tentez donc
d'apporter des réponses aux attentes des
consommateurs ségolène royal s'inquiéter
il ya quelques jours il ne faut pas
reculer sur les actions europe 1 c'est
un des éléments clés de cette loi que
vous évoquez pour permettre donc aux
consommateurs d'obtenir réparation
encore de préjudice commercial est ce
que ségolène royal a raison de
s'inquiéter à la raison regarde
l'histoire de cette mesure elle a été
défendu par jacques chirac puis
abandonnée sous la pression des lobbys
des grandes entreprises à toute
entreprise mais les grandes entreprises
nicolas sarkozy l'avait proposée elle
été abandonnée pour les mêmes raisons et
ce que ségolène royal dit raison de le
dire c'est qu'il ne faut pas plié devant
la pression de ces grandes entreprises
qui ne veulent pas quoi en clair que la
rentrée comme la rente économiques
qu'elles peuvent avoir accumulé par des
pratiques parfois anticoncurrentielles
cette rente économiques soient remises
en cause et redistribués sous forme de
pouvoir d'achat aux consommateurs
cette pression pour la santé par exemple
aujourd'hui de vous vous devez présenter
sa ministre
il a écouté ça qu'aujourd'hui des autres
prises autres cas les chromes
s'organise de telle manière que l'action
groupe à part peut-être pas à son terme
et aucune raison de penser que ce ne
sera pas le cas elle sera votée je
l'espère par le parlement je peux pas
dire elle sera votée sachant que je
respecte évidemment sur les nationales
elle est soutenue par le groupe
socialiste
elle est soutenue par les bien au delà
d'ailleurs de la gauche et il y aura une
action de groupe qui sera inscrite dans
le droit français dans les semaines à
venir
et cette action de groupe disons le elle
comblera quoi ce qui était une lacune en
matière de protection des consommateurs
en france on ne pouvait pas pour les
litiges de consommation du quotidien on
était seuls désormais on pourra se
regrouper pour obtenir réparation les
associations qui sont déjà en plénière
les associations de consommateurs mais
c'est surtout que pour tous ces litiges
du quotidien qui peuvent empoisonner
votre vip vis-à-vis desquels vous étiez
seul auparavant
vous aurez sans avoir à déclenché de
procédure vous même vous pourrez être
représentés et obtenir enfin réparation
du préjudice que vous avez subie dans
tout le champ de l'économie
et des litiges de consommation est un
champ considérable
d'ailleurs qui sont qu'elles sont pas
concernés et certains disent que ça
affaiblit la portée de cet extrait je
pense occasion eh bien je suis en
matière d'environnement et de santé par
exemple le scandale du médiator sur l'a
exclu d'une action de groupe
alors pourquoi parce que l'action de
groupes tels que l' on la conçoit elle
va vous permettre d'obtenir réparation
du préjudice économique subi pour le
médiator n'attendez pas d'être
remboursés du montant des cachets des
pilules que vous avez consommé vous
attendez d'être d'obtenir réparation du
préjudice en terme de santé ce qui
suppose une expertise individuel ce que
le président de la république a dit lors
du conseil des ministres où j'ai
présenté ce texte c'est qu' il s' il
doit y avoir
élargissement du champ d'application à
la santé à l'environnement ce doit être
après l'examen de ce texte qui se limite
aux préjudices économiques parce que
c'est pas dans le code de la
consommation qu'on va pouvoir s'attaquer
à l'action de groupe en matière de santé
ce que là nous sommes dans la réparation
du préjudice économique pour la santé et
l'environnement
il s'agit de la réparation d'un
préjudice de santé una préjudice sur la
nature et c'est un autre type de
procédure qu'il faudra créer mais soyons
clairs le fait qu'ils sont et le champ
d'application soient limités à la
consommation et aux pratiques
anticoncurrentielles ne signifie pas du
tout que la santé et l'environnement
sont écartés des attentions du
gouvernement de légiférer
au contraire il y a vocation à parce que
ce champ des prélocations s'élargissent
d'accord alors autre interrogation est
ce qu'un nouvel instauré le fichier des
français qui ont des crédits parce que
ça devait figurer dans votre texte des
lois et puis bon on l'a pas vu venir
on n'a pas vu venir pourquoi parce que
conseil d'état nous a fait des remarques
me disant tu es lequel vous allez
fichiers 25 millions de personnes ça
concerne à peu près 800 mille personnes
en surendettement
c'est disproportionné ce que j'ai voulu
pour qu être sûrs qu'ils ce que le crès
registre national du crédit et éviter
que le fameux crédits trop c'est
reprendre ma copie et saisir
formellement le conseil d'état sur la
façon de sécuriser juridiquement ce
texte façon à ce qu'il ne soit pas
ensuite invalidée par le conseil
constitutionnel
et pardon est un peu techno mais sous
forme d'amendement gouvernemental
remettront au registre national à venir
donc très vive voix la hes-so tanger en
terre très concret ça permettra tout
simplement aux prêteurs au moment où ils
vous prête ou s'apprêtent à vous vendre
un crédit à la consommation de vérifier
sur un fichier votre solvabilité et ce
sera surtout une manière pour nous cette
fois ci de responsabiliser le prêteur
qui pouvait quand il y avait des
dossiers de surendettement dira écoutez
moi j'ai prêté de l'argent à telle ou
telle personne c'est elle qui est
responsable
elle avait déclaré de bonne foi qu'elle
était solvable elle ne l'était pas là
cette fois ci nous éviterons que l'on
prête le crédit de trous et nous
responsabilise recettes face
concrètement l'établissement crédit
l'établissement bancaire le prêteur
alors là encore c'est un lobby face à
vos achats le lobby bancaire il existe
mais oui ils sont réticentes pour celles
qui dans les faits vont afficher privé
parce qu'à force d'être dominante sur le
marché elles connaissent à peu près la
situation de tous leurs clients
mais la vertu que moi je revendique à ce
registre national du crédit c'est
qu'elle va mettre de la concurrence sur
le marché du crédit est davantage de
concurrence sur le marché du crédit ce
sera des taux qui vont forcément baisser
et je pense que ce permettra notamment
une partie de la population je pense aux
jeunes ménages qui n'ont pas forcément
accès au crédit à la consommation d'y
avoir accès beaucoup plus facilement que
ça n'a été le cas aujourd'hui donc ça
aura des vertus dans la lutte console
surendettement mais sera au des vertus
aussi dans le soutient la consommation
le pouvoir d'achat des ménages notamment
les jeunes ménages
alors question pratique cela ne dépend
pas entièrement de vaud benoît hamon
mais quand est-ce que l'origine de la
viande va-t-elle figurer sur sur
l'emballage des plats préparés alors de
manière volontaire il ya un certain
nombre d'établissements très 2
l'enseigne de la grande distribution qui
veulent de manière volontaire étiqueté
viande bovine française d'un porcine
française et avancer dans ce domaine a
été confirmée aujourd'hui dans une table
ronde que j'ai animée avec guillaume
garot et les professionnels cela étant
dit ce que nous nous souhaiterions les
français et nous avons lyon porter ça
avec stéphane le foll le ministre de
l'agriculture auprès de la commission
européenne nos partenaires européens
c'est que la législation européenne
change on peut sortir par le haut de la
crise de la viande de cheval en faisant
des progrès et l'union européenne a pas
tant que ça d'occasions de montrer
comment elle peut être très concrètement
même poste que je vous redire qu'elle a
pas tant que ça d'occasions de montrer
comment elle peut être concrètement
utiles aux consommateurs européens
là l'occasion en faisant quoi faisant en
sorte que demain dans votre plat préparé
sur l'emballage il y est l'information
dès lors que la vie en est un des
ingrédients l'information sur le lieux
d'abattage lieux d'élevage et le lieu de
naissance bref l'origine de la viande
qui rentre en compte dans la préparation
de votre plat là dessus j'observe quoi
c'est que au départ il ya une belle
mobilisation parce qu'il y avait vous
qui regardez ce que la commission
faisait les journalistes maintenant que
votre regard est ailleurs dans actualité
j'ai vu au je constate que cette
mobilisation a considérablement faibli
de la part 90 de nos partenaires
européens comme de la part de la
commission européenne où on va pas
lâcher la pression on va pas lâcher la
pression parce que mon combat européen
c'est pas normal que la tromperie
économique et exister à échelle qui
aussi grande en europe
et qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est bien
quand on cherche on trouve
pourquoi on a trouvé en français en
france pardon parce qu'on a cherché pour
qu'on a moins trouver ailleurs parce que
je pense qu'on a moins cherché à le
cacher aujourd'hui je pense que cette
affaire-là est loin d'être terminée dès
lors que
on maintient un niveau de contrôle qui
s'assurera et bien que vous ne mangez
pas de cheval à la place de boeuf que
vous mangez pas autre chose à la place
du mouton etc etc et donc je dirais
qu'on va le cacher il sait pas qu'il ya
des scandales cachés il ya des risques
de scandales
dès lors qu'on maintient un modèle
économique qui est celle d'une
alimentation low cost ou à force de
pousser à la baisse des prix pour les
plats que vous achetez et bien vous
pouvez craint que la qualité
l'alimentation qu'il y a dans ses plats
soient de plus en plus mauvaises
et bien moi je ne me résous pas à ce
qu'en europe une grande partie des
classes moyennes des classes populaires
parce que leur budget alimentation est
orienté à la baisse alors pour des
raisons simples leurs salaires
n'augmentent pas leurs pensions
n'augmente pas les dépenses d'énergie
augmente les dispenses de téléphonie
peuvent augmenter les dépenses dites
incompressibles augmente ce budget
alimentation se réduit donc on achète de
moins en moins cher et au bout du compte
on a changé d'horizon moins cher qu'on
mange aussi en l'église moment je
m'arrête des gens ne sais pas comment
nous faire manger et on mange de la
moins bonne qualité je ne me résous pas
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous ne
lâcherons pas la pression ni en france
sur les contrôles toute l'année 2013 sur
la viande et le poisson
or ajoute elle-même est selon la presse
la pression aussi sur la commission
européenne partenaire est ce que vous
êtes favorable à l'ouverture des
magasins de bricolage les dimanches il
ya des députés ps qui se prononcent pour
cette mesure vous en tant que ministre
des consommateurs qui se rappelle
désireux belges ont tous à un gamin
conférence ascendant d'envoyer une
conférence sociale
je souhaite monter les syndicats
s'exprime sur ce sujet jean touya
l'argument emploi oui mais j'ai pigé une
opinion et à une opinion c'est que je
pense qu'en matière de droit du travail
aujourd'hui il faut faire en sorte que
les syndicats puissent donner le la et
moi je considère que à force de rogner
sur le droit du travail par tous les
côtés on va finir par mettre en cause un
bel édifice et je pense que ça doit
relever la négociation entre les
partenaires sociaux avant de savoir s'il
faut des régimes d'exception un peu
partout d'accord c'est votre réponse
donc à ce patron de cette chaîne de
magasins qui veut verser ses boutiques
le dimanche c'est votre réponse est
aussi une partie des députés ps il y
avait déjà la référence sociale
j'entends bio mais que la conférence
sociale donne son avis
et d'abord les partenaires sociaux sur
ce sujet benoît mans vous avez sans
doute été scandalisés comme nous tous
par le drame du bangladesh plus d'un
millier d'ouvriers d'ailleurs
essentiellement des ouvrières enseveli
lors de l'effondrement de ces ateliers
de misère qui fournissent les grandes
chaînes de vêtements occidental afin que
pareille même modèle économique sur
l'avion a dit on ne sait comment ça quoi
salariés à 4 euros de l'heure romain en
allemagne alors c'est pas un salarié au
bangladesh qui est payé quelques
centimètres ronald 32 euros par mois
voilà donc quelques centimes de l'heure
mais c'est le même modèle économique
annoncée on s'est exprimée moi je
souhaite c'est que au delà des chartes
et des engagements on revoit ce qui est
un modèle économique qui est fondée sur
quoi sur le fait aujourd'hui que l'on
exploite la misère de travailleurs au
bangladesh pour se vêtir s'habiller les
uns les autres à des tarifs au bout du
compte le prix quand même coquelles vous
avez acheté votre tee shirts chemises
votre pantalon
il est largement plus élevé que ce qui a
été le coût de production ça veut dire
qu'il ya des gens qui ont marché pour
réaliser des bénéfices et des
intermédiaires parfois assez colossaux
entre temps bien sûr c'est sur ces
points que nous n'avons bien on peut
agir comme ans d'abord en demandant des
explications aux marques françaises qui
sont en aval et aux marques européennes
en aval c'est quoi celle qui distribue
et moi j'attends de savoir et d'en
savoir un peu plus sur la chaîne de
donneurs dante qui amène à ce qu'au bout
de ligne on est des ateliers qui
continue parce que c'est pas hélas un
atelier aujourd'hui s'est effondré avec
des milliers de fois plus de 1000
salariés sont morts mais autres qui
racontent des ateliers qui continuent à
fonctionner et bien moi je pense que
cette responsabilité du donneur dans des
initiales celui qui met sur le marché
elle doit être pointée et j'attends que
les marques françaises voient leur nom
mais d'après nos engagements d'accord
des engagements même s'il faut dire que
le textile permis à bien des états dont
le bangladesh de sortir partiellement de
la misère c'est aussi un facteur positif
mais est il ya la contrepartie
évidemment métallique lourde manière de
sortir de la misère que que celle là si
l'argument c'est dire ces gens là sont
quand même beaucoup plus heureux avec
quelques centimes d'euros qu'il ne
l'était avant
alors qu'ils vont le payer de leur vie
c'est une moss est pas la perspective
que il faut autres cas que je soutiens
ce qu'il faut soutenir aujourd'hui c'est
le fait que c'est pratique qui sont des
pratiques de dumping social qui se fonde
sur la misère des gens et l'exploitation
de la sueur et de la santé de ces gens
cessent d'envoi la pression sur les
donneurs d'ordres occidentaux parce que
c'est facile de parler de la
responsabilité sociétale
environnementale ou sociale des
entreprises où on voit de beaux
affichage sur la rse est derrière et ces
pratiques là la rse c'est pas le fait de
faire travailler des gens comme celle là
parce que sinon ça s'appelle du sur
cholet washing comme on dit c'est à dire
qu'on ont fait une belle lessiveuse ont
fait une belle communication une belle
politique marketing et moi je retiens
que il ya aujourd'hui des ateliers qui
continuent à fonctionner au bangladesh
mais beaucoup d'autres pressions sur les
passes alors d'or et puis
mobilisation des consommateurs alors il
faut également par exemple salue
l'action de l'association éthique sur
l'étiquette voilà en termes d'éthique
êtes vous est-ce que vous conservez
celle de représentants de la gauche
benoît hamon bonne me gêne pas mais vous
gêne pas alors karine perret de la lfp
va nous être vous êtes heureux j'ai sur
votre ligne est votre accord sur la
ligne était fixé l'autre jour par
françois hollande
une social-démocratie assumé avec des
réformes qui passe mal à gauche et si le
chef de l'état remaniée non pas à bercy
mais sa majorité
scénario de politique fiction signée
matt hill de bélanger je suis socialiste
ai-je besoin de me dire social démocrate
est ce que ce serait mieux d'être social
démocrate il se trouve que j'ai dirigé
pendant des années parti socialiste peut
pas appeler le parti social-démocrate
françois hollande n'aime pas se
qualifier ainsi pourtant depuis quelques
mois la ligne du président laisse de
moins en moins de place au doute
rigueur budgétaire pacte de
compétitivité montants dus au patronat
une ligne et qu'une partie du ps
voudrait le voir davantage assumer nous
sommes aujourd'hui au gouvernement avec
nos ministres et au parlement pour la
majorité des sociaux démocrates sur la
méthode
la méthode qui est celle de m le capital
au service de la société et de nos
citoyens et non pas d'être soumis au
marché à la gauche du ps en revanche la
pilule a plus de mal à passer le mois
dernier 35 députés socialistes ont
refusé de voter la réforme du marché du
travail
désormais c'est la loi sur la justice
sociale proposée par le front de gauche
qui divise les parlementaires
socialistes pour mener à bien sa
politique françois hollande pourrait
bien rêver d'une majorité un peu
différente
sa majorité rêver ce serait d'avoir une
majorité socialiste qu'ils soient ultra
majoritairement sur cette ligne et avec
une aile gauche qui soit réduite à la
portion congrue
l'autre élément qui pourrait constituer
un paysage politique plus favorable ce
serait que des responsables politiques
ou des électeurs venant d'autres
horizons
je pense notamment à la sensibilité
centriste puisse accepter éventuellement
de faire une partie de chemin avec lui
françois hollande l'a assuré il n'y a
pas d'ouverture possible gouvernent
monde mais les rapprochements pourraient
avoir lieu lors des prochaines échéances
électorales lors des municipales ou des
européennes 2014 aux questions ministre
représentant de l'ailé gauche
l'étiquette est revendiquée à la haye
l'ouverture au centre ça peut être de la
politique fiction comme le dit le sujet
mais est ce que ce serait pas aussi un
scénario rêvé par le chef de l'état vous
en tant que représentant neil gauche ce
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense que c'est une fable qu'on soit
sur la joue droite les deux le corps du
milieu les legouge tout ça est une fable
c'est un vieux marronnier ça va encore
faire parler le présent totalement dit
que c'était qui n'est absolument pas à
l'ordre du jour mais bon moi je pense
que c'est un scénario qui n'a aucune
crédibilité ni politique encore moins de
consistant sur le plan d'une majorité
parlementaire avec qui vous voulez vous
la faire avec le modem qui a comme une
députée un charismatique c'est une
majorité parlementaire ça se fait pas et
du charisme ça se fait avec des députés
et le fait que françois hollande refuse
se définir comme social-démocrate
lors de sa conférence de presse à vous a
rassuré mais non parce que je veux juste
dire une chose la social démocratie
tout le monde n'a su ni au parti
socialiste pourquoi parce que je crois
qu'on ne sait pas bien ce que le sens de
ce mot le parti social démocrate
allemand c'est un vieux parti qui est un
parti qui était pas moins marquée à
gauche on était parti socialiste même
plus marquées parfois à gauche que le
mettait le parti socialiste et la social
démocratie nous sommes dans la
social-démocratie ya plusieurs courants
de la social démocratie je confonds
social libéralisme et social démocratie
le courant social démocrate il inclut
les socialistes français après qu'est ce
que ça veut dire la social démocratie
telle que je crois la comprendre dans la
bouche de certains journalistes
dans la réalité ce serait le social
libéralisme je ne crois pas que le
président la république ait choisi une
voie sociale libérale
là où il a choisi une méthode qui nous
différencie évidemment de nos
prédécesseurs et peut-être un tout petit
peu de ce qu'on avait pu faire dans les
années 80 c'est le choix du dialogue
social les cgu le choix de faire de la
négociation sociale
une forme de préalables à la loi avec un
pari qui était un pari important dans un
contexte où le rapport de forces n'est
pas forcément très favorable au salarié
une entreprise par entreprise et où il
faut justement revigorer les conditions
dans lesquelles les salariés font
entendre leur voix
et c'est cette méthode qui rapproche
probablement aujourd'hui l'exercice du
pouvoir en france de ce qu'on a pu
constater en allemagne de ce qu'on a pu
constater de la culture social démocrate
suédoise nordiques etc scandinave pour
faire vite
de ce point de vue là on peut dire qu'il
ya un rapprochement avec un modèle qui
est un modèle allemand ou un modèle
alors qu'on aurait étonné là on va
parler des réformes de fond mais c'est
le plus c'est le plus important parce
que après je conteste qu'aujourd'hui on
soit sûr une dérive qui est une dérive
parce que ce serait une pour le coup
vers le centre ou vers la droite - on
parlait donc de dialogue social bientôt
la conférence sociale mois de juin va
aborder un gros dossier le sujet des
retraites
françois hollande a dit là dessus qu'il
faudrait travailler plus longtemps
vous dites oui oui à faire sur la
question de l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation moi ma position est la
suivante
moi je considère qu'on ne peut pas
mettre à signe égal entre quelqu'un qui
est un cadre qui n'aura pas eu
d'exposition majeure au stress ou en
tout cas d un travail qui affecte sa
santé soit parce qu'il ya peu de travail
posté de travail de l'extérieur de port
de charges etc et celui qui
a été exposée à des risques qui vont
réduire son espérance de vie
la réalité c'est que nous savons
aujourd'hui que sont les métiers où les
branches dans lesquelles on travaille on
n'a pas la même espérance de vie une
fois que l'on part à la retraite
et moi je considère qu'il est venu le
moment où il va falloir mettre sur la
table la question de la pénibilité qui
doit dire quoi c'est qu'il y ait un
certain nombre de métiers que vous allez
peut-être d'avoir un code
durant votre vie ou une année travaillée
doit valoir une virgule une une virgule
2 une virgule trois années cotisées de
façon à ce que cela n'ait pas cotiser 44
annuités alors qu'ils ont déjà une
espérance de vie qui est beaucoup plus
courte que les autres et qui réduirait
considérablement le temps qu'ils vont
passer à la retraite et quelques et les
dernières années dans des conditions où
physiquement ils ont du mal en plus à
aller jusqu'au bout
donc il faut faire la différence entre
ces métiers qui sont des métiers durs et
qui sont pas que des métiers physiques
il peut y avoir à son de métier où on
est exposé à des tâches répétitives ou à
un niveau de stress à des formes de
management qui exposent à des
pathologies mais que ce travail là soit
fait et ce que je veux dire c'est que
moi je n'accepterai pas une réponse qui
de la part notamment d'un certain nombre
d'organisations patronales nous disent
c'est trop compliqué la pénibilité on
est capable de faire aujourd'hui des
moyennes ou en fonction des métiers
on sait que et bien après votre retraite
en moyenne vous n'avez que huit années à
vivre et d'autres vous avez une 20 à
vivre eh bien on doit pouvoir travailler
à cela et je me méfierais dans ce
domaine là d'un registre un peu
incantatoire que j'ai pu entendre ou à
droite ou de la part de tous mais d'une
part de numération partie des pressions
or sur les projets du gouvernement parce
qu'on entend tous mais si l'allongement
de la durée de cotisation
ça ne peut pas être de la même manière
pour tous parce qu'il doit y avoir prise
en compte de la pénibilité ça c'est mon
métier que vous auriez donc non pénible
ça c'est quelque chose qui vous gêne
mais ça change tout parce que savoir que
parce que du coup on est donc mais on
n'arrive pas le même discours en 2010 et
je tiens compte de ce qu'ils de la
situation actuelle arrive au jeu
on se souvient de manifestations
communes par exemple j'ai jean luc
mélenchon sur les retraites lui il va
confier à descendre dans la rue tout le
parti socialiste à manifester oui il
n'ya pas que benoît hamon et jean luc
mélenchon et je me souviens tout une
partie socialiste a manifesté de dans sa
totalité
contre la réforme fillon qui était censé
mettre à l'équilibré moindre
contradiction et vous même on a
l'impression qu'il s'est plaint de ne
pas être contre il sait pas que je ne
veux pas être en contre et je souhaite
qu'il y ait le maintien d'un système par
répartition qui soit si possible
équilibré sur le plan financier et qui
tiennent compte de quoi ce que je n'ai
cessé de réclamer avec beaucoup d'autres
du fait qu'on n'ait pas égaux devant la
retraite selon qu'on soit une femme ou
un homme selon cosson un travailleur sur
des métiers pénibles ou pas on n'est pas
des go
aujourd'hui il ya un enjeu fondamental à
dire quoi à dire que pour ceux qui ont
eu un métier pénible ces années de
métier pénible de les amener à cotiser -
1 avec bureau est très pénible c'est
beau ça nous met pas du stress
stress des cadres c'est passionnant
c'est vrai que c'est pas leur métier
physique comme vous le définissez mai
puis des il est plus facile de mesurer
aujourd'hui l'impact des filières ou des
métiers où des gens ont passé leur vie à
travailler poster des travailler à
l'extérieur mais cette question de la
pénibilité
elle est à mes yeux au coeur elle doit
être au coeur de la négociation sociale
gens tombent et jeunes en disant ça je
ne crois pas être en contradiction avec
qui que ce soit parce que ce sera aussi
la position du gouvernement
très bien un autre sujet notre dossier
c'est les relations entre la france et
l'allemagne on a vu un texte du parti
socialiste fin avril qui poussait
hollande au bras de fer avec la
chancelière angela merkel et puis depuis
jean marc ayrault puis françois hollande
n'ont cessé de parler de la langue
l'importance de la relation
franco-allemande est ce que ça vous a
pas un peu déçu oui on peut dire qu'il
faut une que la relation franco
allemande est essentielle elle l'est
sans pour autant dire qu'il faut faire
comme nicolas sarkozy est soumis nicolas
sarkozy était soumis à madame merkel
président de la république à lui obtenir
en un an
la réorientation de la politique
européenne contre la vie qui l'amène à
mme merkel n'était pas favorable à ce
délai supplémentaire donnée nous
constatons que l'action qui est celle
d'où les c'est pour ça que je vais faire
délibérément parlera peut-être de bercy
et l'action conjointe d'un pierre
moscovici qui parle travail de
conviction prépare le terrain et
d'arnaud montebourg et aux autres moi et
quelques-uns qui faisons vivre aussi une
parole française des marges dans un camp
quand même hein mais non est ce que je
oublions ça je pense que c'est
complémentaire le but il était quoi
président de la république voulait que
le rythme de consolidation budgétaire le
rythme auquel on réduit les déficits se
fasse pas au détriment de la croissance
oris pas c'est quoi c'est que si on
avait écouté aujourd'hui ce qui était
les rythmes vous lis par la commission
européenne est poussé par les allemands
au départ nous aurions encore plus de
récession partout en europe et nous
aurions france une situation bien pire
c'était le choix qu'avait fait nicolas
sarkozy avant nous avons décidé de
prendre un autre chemin
nous avons gagné là dessus et que ce
soit dit ah oui mais attendez je veux
d'abord vous avez retire le serbe est
une opportunité non réformé nous avons
gagné oui et quand on gagne
politiquement là où aucun pays aucune
coalition n'avait obtenu le moindre
délai le moindre remise en cause des
sacro-saints précis qui étaient ceux de
la commission européenne totalement
dédié à son objectif des 3%
nous l'avons obtenu c'est une victoire
politique
elle est dû à quoi à l'action de
françois hollande servi par son
gouvernement et ses ministres qui se
déroule 10 complémentaires ag fait l'âme
soeur d'une france low cost aujourd'hui
alors sur tous les jours j'ai la plus
grosse low-cost la partie mais mais
pourquoi je la peur d'une france low
cost mais parce que le modèle économique
qui est défendue par une majorité des
gouvernements conservateurs en europe
une majorité des commissaires au collège
des commissaires issus de ces
gouvernements c'est ce modèle économique
et je pense au modèle économique
tragique pour nos modèles sociaux
pourquoi parce qu'à force de tirer les
verts l'économie low cost défaut réduire
les coûts de production
si vous réduisez les coûts de production
par les entreprises demandent une
réduction du coût du travail et donc une
réduction de votre salaire une réduction
de la contribution de vaud des
entreprises pour payer votre sécurité
sociale et pour payer vos retraites
allié à la force nous aurons à force
nous aurons quoi nous aurons une
sécurité sociale low cost ou en tout cas
on aura une sacrée de vitesse quand vous
aurez les moyens de vous payer une
complémentaire vous vous lapeyrère si
vous n'êtes oui c'est déjà un peu le cas
vous avez entièrement raison
mais justement moi je ne me résous pas à
l'idée que finalement les protections ce
soit réservé qu'à ceux qui ont les
moyens de se les payer
or nous luttons contre cela pour cela il
faut lutter contre un modèle économique
locaux
qui est quand même tragique en europe
quand on pense qu'on était enviée dans
le monde entier en raison de notre
richesse mais aussi notre haut niveau de
protection sociale et au niveau de
service public
vous nous sacrifier et l'un et l'autre
pour vouloir être en théorie aussi riche
mais j'observe que depuis 20 ans fait
pas beaucoup de croissance en europe
mais que ce sont surtout les plus riches
qu'ils soient plus riches mais que tous
les autres s'appauvrissent moi je ne
souhaite pas sa gêne et des élections
européennes seront déterminantes pour
changer cela paraît une dernière
question la question sur jérôme cahuzac
l'ex ministre du budget qui souhaite
enfin qui laisse planer le doute sur un
éventuel retour aux municipales de 2014
dans son fief ce que c'est un boulet
pour le gouvernement pour les
socialistes
mais moi je ne suis pas dans sa tête
jérôme cahuzac je le connais assez je
suis content qu'il ait fait ce choix de
ne pas revenir je pense que je pense
qu'il faut passer à autre chose pense
qu'il faut qu'il ouvre un autre chapitre
personnel et tant qu'il restera sur ce
chapitre
d'abord je pense que pour son propre
camp sa propre famille politique et je
crois qu'il est attaché
ce ne sera pas bon et je pense que mais
je sais pas s'il acceptera mais mes
conseils je pense que pour lui-même ce
ne sera pas une once de confiance au
sujet une dernière question est-ce que
élevé doit se présenter ce qu'on doit
avoir un candidat avait levé pour la
législative je crois que dans le
contexte qui est celui monter très fort
du front national qui moi me tarde et
l'écologiste lepez parce que je pense
que nous avons là affaire un danger très
fort où je pense que dans ce contexte
est celui de cette élection il faut une
candidature si possible unique de la
gauche
merci karine ferri tarnos de public
sénat arrive à nous rejoindre mais
normalement et si votre ambition passer
par une sortie du gouvernement même si
vous entendez là on vous entendu à quel
point satisfait si vous êtes le seul
membre de revendiquer de gauche tribu
ainsi intel satisfecit au chef de l'état
enquête menée par faustine sa jeunesse
il a fait le grand écart et a dû
renoncer à son style bien trempé de
porte parole du parti socialiste benoît
hamon est l'un des rares représentants
de la gauche de la gauche au
gouvernement avec arnaud montebourg
mais ils peinent parfois à se faire
entendre face aux ministres du
redressement productif plus flamboyant
une critique balayée d'un revers de main
par son ami david assouline également
porte parole du parti socialiste
quelques le très combative l'opinion
qu'est-ce qu'on connait c'est moi mais
là justement on connaît si je sais que
ce n'est pas ça qui va d'ailleurs avec
ce côté opiniâtre et ce n'est pas on va
dire la tchatche la flamboyance qui a
fait ce qu'il est puisque vous comparez
incarne aux nouveaux ils n'ont jamais eu
même si le problème dans un gouvernement
on même dans une équipe n'est pas de
flamboyer plus que l'autre benoît hamon
serait donc plutôt un bétonneur celui
qui se place derrière la ligne de
défense pour colmater les brèches au
football c'est d'ailleurs son rôle
lorsqu'il joue avec ses camarades du ps
mais si la tendance sociale démocrate du
gouvernement se confirme il sera de plus
en plus difficile pour benoît de faire
entendre sa voix benoît hamon fait
partie de ces ministres qui sont qu'il
abhorre qui parle qui donnent leur point
de vue qu'ils sont écoutés
après je vous cache pas que évidemment
le on va dire l'orientation actuelle du
gouvernement de mon point de vue
mériterait de sérieuses inflexion
et ça mais ça c'est pas pour aller c'est
pas la faute de benoît hamon se dire
c'est aussi un cap a été donnée par le
président de la république pour se faire
entendre benoît hamon pour elle se
tourner vers l'île de france
certains lui prédisent un avenir à la
présidence de la région pour succéder à
jean paul huchon à condition que celui
ci accepte de céder son siège à la
mairie tanoh nous a rejoints quand vos
questions aux bétonneurs on dit le
flingueur on disait le flingueur qu'on
vous étiez porte parole du bes sas est
le nouveau visage de benoît hamon c'est
à dire un style un peu moins flamboyant
un peu moins cogneur pour celui de
bossert quand on est ministre on est
attendue sur ces dossiers moi j'ai la
consommation j'ai le l'économie sociale
et solidaire sont deux gros dossiers g2o
en préparation
m'attends pas faire mon petit numéro
/
voilà bien deux et c'est pour ça c'est
que je pense que j'ai quand je pense que
j'ai à dire quelque chose et que a
exprimé un désaccord je les fais et je
suis même pas beaucoup entendu benoît
mans on a beaucoup dit il avale des
couleuvres sein des gouvernements mais
parce qu on en dise un quand je parle on
dit que par le trou et quand je parle
page avaler des couleuvres de toute
façon on n'a jamais le beau rôle dans
ces cas là mais moi je sais juste que on
est collectivement c'est un collectif
laisse moi j'ai un objectif dans le
monde sait que le chômage
sa courbe soit inversée à la fin de
l'année 2013 pour ma part du boulot
c'est qu'il ya les emplois d'avenir la
moitié d'entre eux cependant l'économie
sociale et solidaire on arrive à en
faire 50 milles pour ce qui nous
concerne nous chez les jeunes peu ou pas
qualifiés dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire ce sera une contribution
extrêmement importante donc oui on est
attendu sur le fait de travailler je
suis pas porte parole
dans ce gouvernement coupât parole du ps
s'est éteint une activité qui devait
m'amener à cogner effectivement et je
regrette pas de ce nom ces moments là
mais je suis très content d'être passé
aussi autre chose on a quand même peu
entendu vos désaccords vous me dites que
vous avez eu parfois des désaccords
depuis très trop gouvernement j'ai pas
là pour faire l'inventaire de sa a été
suffisamment noter au moment où je les
ai exprimé mais si vous en souvenez pas
ce sujet un problème mais c'est dans
cette austérité on vous entendu sur la
retraite ailleurs en visant qu'à vous
étiez sur la ligne mais bon quand même
dans mes réserves
moi je il ya des cadres dans lesquels
aujourd'hui le premier ministre nous
permet que le débat existe une fois que
le débat est tranché il est tranché si
demain je devais avoir comme n'importe
quel ministre y'a pas que benoît hamon
arnaud montbourg un désaccord qui
m'amène à être à penser que on fait
fausse route vis-à-vis de qui des
classes populaires
mais elle est exprimée ce désaccord si
je ne pense qu'il n'a pas de solutions
dans l'activité de ce gouvernement j'en
tirerai les conséquences comme tout le
monde mais il faut arrêter deux êtres
gouvernement ce n'est pas tous les jours
faire l'inventaire des couleuvres qu'on
avale des petites et des grandes
trahisons ça n'est pas vrai moi mon
quotidien c'est de faire en sorte que
demain il ya l'action groupe qui sait
qui couine par ne l'exposerai pas joli
mais qui crient les grands groupes
est ce que ça montre que ce gouvernement
a choisi de s'aligner derrière le cac 40
non l'exact contraire quand je prépare
le registre national des crédits pour
responsabiliser les prêteurs les
prêteurs qui plaît nord en apparence un
monde que ce gouvernement n'est pas
aligné derrière les les grands groupes
quand je prépare dans la loi économie
sociale et solidaire des dispositions
c'est la reprise par les salariés de
leur entreprise
là encore je ne sens pas le medef très
enthousiaste c'est la démonstration très
impressionnant est vraiment dans votre
rôle dans votre notamment de route d'aix
représentants de la gauche
aujourd'hui si on est le problème c'est
pour l'étiquette halal à prouilhe mais
j'ai accepté gérer emmanuel morel c'est
qui est un un brillant représentant de 2
7l là aujourd'hui et dans beaucoup de
cette expression j'entends des choses
qui font écho à mes à mes propres
combats et en même temps david assouline
il disait il est pourtant eu du parti
socialiste jordi il connaît les
servitudes et l'intérêt du job en
quelque sorte fait en même temps il dit
l'essentiel quand on est ministre on est
plus court parole ba voila je suis
ministre je ne suis plus porte parole m
qu'à un moment quand même que ce soit
lui des eaux est ce qu'à un moment quand
même benoît hamon vous avez dressé le
bilan de votre participation au
gouvernement il ya six mois dans
libération vous disiez j'attends de
connaître le véritable sol de ce
gouvernement de faire la part des choses
entre les décisions véritablement de
gauche est ce que vous appelez vous les
décisions de drôle c'est à dire à la
femme de droite et de gauche mais aussi
à la danse et c'est pas toujours
appliquée ministre de de roches au
gouvernement on voit bien ce que c'est
la drum presse
c'est une expression qui disait une
forme de kannad ride de la gauche comme
on a pu en voir
oui c'est une forme de oui voilà c'est
exactement mais je veux pas épiloguer
là-dessus
ce que je crois c'est que moi je que je
constate c'est qui a
vingt ans déjà on expliquait que le bout
du tunnel était pour bientôt et que les
gens ils ont du mal à voir la lumière
bien que nous sommes attendus sur sur ça
et une grande partie du scepticisme qui
explique la montée du front national
c'est beaucoup mon sentiment que droite
ou gauche
je le vis et président de la république
deux scènes et le prémice aussi beaucoup
de nos concitoyens pensent qu'il n'ya
plus rien à attendre
ces deux familles là qu'en réalité le
bout du tunnel il viendra pas pour rien
je pense que c'est là dessus que nous
sommes attendus dans ce quinquennat dans
la démonstration que pour les classes
populaires c'est à dire les gens qui
vivent de leur travail qui aimerait en
vivre ce qu'ils n'ont pas assez de
salaires qu'une petite retraite qui sont
chômage qui vont retrouver de l'emploi
que pour cela on les débarrasse de ce
qu'ils leur empoisonne la vie en matière
d'accès aux soins d'accès à l'éducation
pour leurs enfants de logements dans
lesquels il est difficile de vivre de
factures dont on ne sait pas se sortir
c'est là dessus que nous sommes attendus
si ça bouge un peu là dessus si on fait
bouger les lignes là je pense qu'on aura
la modifier quelque chose de fondamental
dans la vie des français
c'est que il recommencera à croire dans
l'action collective une action politique
pas c'est là dessus que je suis mobilisé
et pour commencer il ya un objectif
inverser la courbe du chômage fin 2013
c'est notre job à tous où sera jugé là
dessus avant de savoir faire du bla bla
bla moi je travaille
vos partenaires à les verts sont un peu
plus dubitatif sur les critiques très
critique même si on écoute jean vincent
placé par exemple le président du groupe
écologiste
ici au sun au sénat combien de temps les
ministres verts peuvent rester au
gouvernement
le plus longtemps possible j'espère moi
je vous dis d'abord outre deux
excellents ministre oui mais ces
licences mais sans eux sans vie dans un
gouvernement qui ne serait composée que
de socialistes et radicaux
ce serait la grande baie ans qui va bien
au delà de seul parti europe ecologie
les verts leur contribution au débat
économique au débat politique
il ya mes yeux indispensable ce qu'ont
rapporté depuis dix ans les verts au
débat politique
s'ils n'étaient pas représentés dans
l'action de ce gouvernement mais très
critique va être à la fois du
gouvernement être écrit alors rien à la
gauche ce n'est pas la droite on n'est
pas dans la caporalisation moi j'accepte
qu'on a 50 ans il faut quand même
à vire puisse naviguer cécile duflot
solidarité la plus élémentaire avec ce
qu à ce gouvernement qu'une seule fois
jamais et moi je considère aujourd'hui
qu'elle est un des poids lourds
politiques de ce gouvernement dont il
faut tout faire pour qu'elle use ses
amis restent et se sentent impliqués
dans ce gouvernement
le projet de loi sur l'enseignement
supérieur arrive demain à l'assemblée
nationale benoît hamon avec notamment
une disposition qui fait pas mal parler
d'elle sur la possibilité de dispenser
certains courants en anglais dans les
facs est ce que vous êtes pour ou est-ce
qu'on est contre à écouter s'est
défendue par ma collègue gnfe fioraso
donc comme chez amazon moi je suis pour
je pense qu'il faut discuter voilà il
faut qu'il discute ça devait totalement
non mais je pense nous mais c'est passé
pas aussi je viens de vous dire que
c'est pour je pense que c'est pas
nouveau j ai aucun humour vous voulez
chercher des problèmes là où il y en a
partout mais là encore il ya une
division spéciale série mais on veut
savoir votre goût sur paris
on n'a pas fait lire 300 béni oui oui
l'ambition des objets des sujets
politiques les députés autant d'opinions
lankais lançait-il mac pour les rendre
compétitifs donc moi je pense qu'il faut
qu'elle discute avec les parlementaires
qui ont exprimé des réserves
c'est-à-dire revenir un peu sur cette
disposition c'est à dire un trouver une
bonne solution quand on veut avoir des
amendements aux lois consommation ce
sont en fait des combats moi je vais
passer des compromis dans le cadre du
projet de loi consommation si le
compromis auquel le pas ce n'est pas
possible il y en aura pas bon les élus
ump qui ont prévu d'aller manifester
encore dimanche prochain aux côtés des
opposants au mariage pour tous
est-ce qu'ils sont à leur place dans la
rue alors que la loi a déjà été
promulguée chiens juste que je pense
qu'ils sont totalement perdus quoi à
l'ump que ils sont totalement paumées à
savoir à ce qu on manifestait ce qu'on
manifeste pas ce qu'on fait campagne
contre nkm ou pas paris et je sens
surtout des droits liés à quoi une fête
qui n'ont pas fait l'inventaire du
sarkozysme ils sont dans une relation
idolâtre à nicolas sarkozy qui les
empêche de faire le bilan voire a
tellement redouté son retour qui ne
veulent pas faire l'inventaire de ce qui
a été bien mauvais de leurs points de
vue et des résultats quand on tombe dès
lors qu'on propose une mesure d'économie
nous disent non il faut pas faire
d'économies mais après 10 n'allait pas
assez loin
ils ont fait ça oui oui oui mais les
yeux noirs mais d'aller plus loin mais
l'engin quoi c'est la famille les
entreprises pas sur la défense on sait
pas sur quoi
après ils nous disent faut pas augmenter
les impôts ils ont augmenté plus que
nous lui avons fait et donc aux ce qui
est très frappant c'est cette forme de
vide de contradictions permanentes sur
le mariage gai écoute et je pense
maintenant la loi a été validée par le
conseil constitutionnel
la première fois j'ai pas c'est pas le
fait qu'ils soient dans la rue c'est je
pense qu'ils sont à la remorque d'un
mouvement dont ils ont peur qu'il leur
échappe
pour ce que tout l'enjeu pour jean
françois copé c'est la récupération
politique de la manif pour tous c'est la
récupération politique de ces voix là et
est même s'il doit se faire au prix de
compromission sur le fond et au jour et
aujourd'hui dans la coexistence avec la
droite radicale et l'extrême droite
l'ump en chaîne de plus en plus de
compromission sur le fond n'était qu'à
voir les déclarations du député
andalouse de vialatte le député sûr
taubira christine taubira et les
dissuader il a réuni 800 tonnes il a
retiré s'est suicidé ce mardi à notre
dame de paris
un essayiste d'extrême droite qui
s'appelle dominique venner qui a
expliqué qu' il faisait ce geste
notamment en raison de la loi infâme sur
le mariage gay marine le pen a réagi en
disant que c'était un geste éminemment
politique
écoutez c'est suicide d'un homme devant
l'autel oui bah écoutez c'est
effectivement avec force force de
symbole je pense que dans ce qu'il est à
100 d'image qui ont été manipulés
à l'occasion de cette loi là où en tout
cas de débat autour de ce texte
on a vu resurgir un vieux fond d'extrême
droite dans ce pays qui m'inquiète moi
beaucoup mais ce qui m'inquiète encore
plus c'est sa tombe de silence de la
droite par rapport à un durcissement une
partie de sa base je rappelle que la loi
ne vais rien à aucun citoyen elles n'ont
levé rien à leur donner à d'autres et
garantit l'égalité des droits
mais elle ne vais rien à aux comptes ce
qui est qui manifestaient ce qui
n'empêche pas de dialoguer pourquoi
parce que ce dialogue illégitime avec
ceux qui sont contre mais je trouve que
voilà il ya un air qui un adversaire qui
parfois inquiétante merci merci maman
merci perrine bonsoir à tous et à très
vite
une semaine politique et parlementaire
passé au crible de l'image et du
questionnement la compétitivité
maintenant c'est un problème le coût du
travail qui n'était pas un problème qui
n'existait pas et maintenant un problème
la crise écologique et plus en plus
vivre eh bien on a besoin de changer les
choses et rapidement parlement hebdo
pour ne rien manquer pour tout
comprendre
c'est vendredi à 17h45
j'ai affirmé que la grande priorité du
prochain quinquennat sera l'école
l'éducation
je revendique les 60000 postes
d'enseignants de surveillants
d'assistante sociale d'un cerbère
nous avons besoin de 150 mille
professeurs pour l'essence pour les cinq
années qui viennent pas pour les
professeurs pour eux mêmes mais pour
former des millions et 10 millions
d'enfants nous avons douze millions
d'élèves scolarisés aujourd'hui dans le
système
ils sont la france de demain
l'école de la république grandes
priorités affichées du quinquennat pour
réfléchir au recrutement et à la
formation des professeurs jacques
bernard magner sénateur du puy de dôme
et ancien enseignant a dirigé pendant
quatre mois un groupe de travail
objectif nourrir la future loi sur la
refondation de l'école grâce à une
trentaine d'auditions au sénat et à des
déplacements dans différentes académies
il y a donc trois grands objectifs
d'abord de retrouver un vivier qui
permettent d'assurer la pérennité du
métier d'enseignant parce que quand on
met des enseignants il faut qu'il y ait
des gens qui va ici former ensuite
retrouvé une base sociale plus large une
assiette sociales plus larges du
recrutement puisque on revient que pour
le master ya une forme entre guillemette
d'embourgeoisement de ceux qui
bénéficient de ces formations et enfin
une meilleure formation tout au long de
leur scolarité jusqu'au master de ceux
qui seront enseignants
le gouvernement ayrault souhaite
recruter massivement et vite
cent cinquante mille enseignants dans
les cinq prochaines années cela
correspond aux 54 mille créations de
postes promesse de françois hollande
pendant la campagne présidentielle
auxquels s'ajoutent les presque 100
milles départ à la retraite qu'il faudra
compenser une urgence de recrutement que
partagent les personnalités auditionnées
par le groupe de travail les besoins de
recrutement on le sait ce sont et seront
considérables pour diverses raisons et
en particulier les raisons
démographiques
c'est pas tout à fait maintenant ou
jamais mais je me sens quand à travers
toute la concertation il ya le sentiment
très fort que il fallait effectivement
on en était à un moment clé est que ceux
qui ne se seraient pas maintenant ne
serait peut-être pas après que si on
veut préserver une certaine idée de
l'école de ce que de ce qu'est l'école
dans la société
il fallait évidemment aboutir et réussit
à fric
une situation très perceptible sur le
terrain à 1500 euros nets en début de
carrière après cinq ans d'études
les candidats ne se bousculent pas au
portillon anaïs crapet est une de ces
nouvelles professeurs stagiaires cette
année à villejuif en banlieue parisienne
après avoir réussi son concours l'an
passé sa matière les mathématiques est
l'une des plus frappée par la crise des
vocations
donc là titre du chapitre opérations sur
les nombres en écriture fractionnaire
l'an dernier près d'un tiers des 950
postes ouverts en mathématiques n'ont
pas été pourvus et ce sera sans doute
encore le cas à la rentrée 2013
une image dégradée du métier et des
conditions de travail peu attractif
décourage nombre d'étudiants 58 pour
devenir professeur de mathématiques avec
le même niveau de la thématique et 10g
ou deux à l'équivalent de la licence on
peut aller faire une école d'ingénieurs
alors c'est sur le temps de travail
n'est pas le même salaire non plus donc
ça peut expliquer la crise des vocations
en tout cas dans les mathématiques ça
c'est sûr et puis cinq ans d'études
c'est dissuasif aussi
rien cinq ans dès qu il faut les
financer on les fait dans des grandes
villes et mathématiques lettres anglais
allemands ou encore musique
nombreuses sont les matières où les
besoins de recrutement ne sont pas
comblés dans le secondaire l'école
primaire n'est pas épargné les syndicats
enseignants tirent la sonnette d'alarmé
sur la chute vertigineuse du nombre
d'aspirants aux contres il ya six ans et
on va dire 3000 candidats qui postulait
pour les postes premier degré sur une
petite académie comme poitou charentes
aujourd'hui on en est à 200 donc la
question du vivier elle se pose
aujourd'hui très sincèrement elle est
parfois très très grave y compris dans
des académies qui ont toujours été
stable et attractive pour raviver la
flamme de l'enseignement chez les
étudiants le ministère a lancé une
grande campagne d'affichage dans toute
la france est axé son discours sur la
priorité donnée à l'éducation et donc à
des emplois sécurisé en pleine période
de crise
je lance aujourd'hui un appel solennel à
la jeunesse française
nous avons besoin de nouvelles lumières
républicaine nous avons besoin de
nouveaux hussards noirs
nous avons besoin de la jeunesse
française pour redresser la france est
ensemble bâtir un autre avenir mais
aucune recette miracle n'émerge pour
attirer les étudiants
au fil des auditions au sénat il ressort
pourtant que c'est peut-être du côté de
la formation que l'accent doit être mis
certains professeurs n'ayant jamais vu
une classe avant d'exercer le
recrutement précoce des enseignants
c'est une manière de préparer aussi des
enseignants qui ne découvre pas le
métier en ayant le concours ce qui est
évidemment le drame actuel et c'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui je suis allée
la femme de bordeaux lire les jeunes
sont dans une situation de désarroi réel
et profond et non seulement ils sont peu
nombreux mais en plus on crée les
conditions pour que éventuellement il
raccroche
avant même d'avoir commencé les
auditions s'enchaînent et des pistes de
formation précoce font leur chemin
pourquoi ne pas imaginer des stages dès
la licence pour les étudiants afin
qu'ils aient une idée